hey everybody and welcome to a special
wild ride where we're talking to
arguably the greatest mixed martial
artist
of all time yeah that's right
plus probably the nicest mixed martial
artist of all time
this guy is a legend so let's get into
it
ladies and gentlemen george st pierre
yeah dude now i'd like you to meet my
co-host scott randolph how's it going
george
and hi how are you good good very well
right on and up at the front of the van
we have the gorgeous paul briskey
hey george how are you fantastic thank
you good to see you before we do
anything
let's wish the man a happy birthday he's
talking to us
on his birthday happy birthday thanks
yeah 440 years old my goodness
the big 4-0 yeah yeah yeah
big 4-0 exactly but you know what
everything is closed
here so there's like a curfew
the restaurants are closed everything is
closed the gyms are closed so there's
nothing to do really much so
it doesn't really matter to me you know
what i mean so i just uh
my mom gave me a cake and that was that
that that's about
it okay all right well this will be your
birthday party
i don't quite understand yeah yeah yeah
exactly i'm doing my birthday
party with you guys i love it it's an
honor yeah thank you so much
is that a george st perriere
that's epic sorry but uh
so why is everything closed man the
world's opening up dude i got my second
vaccination shot
you know like well it's because we're
always behind you guys in canada
i'm from montreal so we're always late
what you guys have we always have it
late
so it sucked but that's how it is you
know i guess
we're always a few months behind you
guys okay so
so everything's been locked down for
the whole time yeah they they announced
that it will re
it will open uh june in june but only
the
the outside the patio seating areas for
the restaurant
okay that's crazy quick question if you
were
after a fight you get seriously injured
would you rather go to a canadian
hospital or an american hospital
oh that's a good question american when
i
when i blew my my two acl i went to u.s
and the reason is
yes in canada the health system is free
the health care system is accept
accessible to everybody
every citizen however they treat
everybody the same so
and a professional athlete for example
my body is my
instrument of work so i would have the
same treatment
as uh a 70 years old
lady so that's why i went to u.s because
in us you pay for it but you
you can have special treatment in order
to rehab
better and faster okay wow cool
you know like uh nobody has to pay for
for health care
in canada but you know you get the same
medical care as some [ __ ] [ __ ]
some smoke
you know what you wait a very long time
let's say you go to
yeah normally you go you go to it for uh
like something
to the hospital you have to wait for a
very long time so yeah
there are some advantages but there's
some bad
issues with it as well yeah your your
appendix explodes and you're there for
eight hours just right
freaking out oh yeah oh yeah
it's it's it's bad yeah it's like
canadian patience
i love
um now you're uh you're not haven't been
inducted to the hall of fame
yet is that correct but but this is a
guarantee you're the greatest of all
time
okay thank you i'm not sure about that
there's a lot of guys that can claim the
to be the the goat uh it's very
subjective
as you know to say that
but but yeah i'm inducted to the hall of
fame but they the
party has not happened yet because i
thought so they announced it
but they didn't made it they made it
official but they didn't really make the
the the celebration that comes with it
well congratulations on
being a hall of famer man that's awesome
and
thank you man thank you and very few
people
are in the conversation about the
greatest of all time right i mean who
are we talking about you hear
jon jones gsp could be
the problem i think guys is that there's
some of them
that could be in the conversation but
they stay
and hang out way too long past their
prime in the sport so they kind of
tarnish their legacy unfortunately yeah
i think that when i think about uh
silva or uh andre are alive and
you know they could have retired on top
and being like the
like the goat but unfortunately they are
too long
and that's a problem that makes perfect
sense
and uh i was gonna say the same thing
about anderson silva i feel like
you know who who's on your list for the
goat
well there's a few uh it depends for
which reason
if you talk about the guy who made the
who changed the sport change martial art
my number one goat is royce gracie
yeah he's for me the best of all time
because you have done stuff
in his poorest time that i believe will
never be repeated
however if you ask me if i would put
rice gracie in
the ufc right now against the the
the fighters of that era i don't think
he would do well
but for his era he was the best he was
the best of all time
i believe the best the best fighters is
not even born yet
because recorders are made to be broken
if you talk about who's
legit legitimately the the real goat i
don't think he's born yet because
the fighters of today are better than
the one of yesterday
and the one of tomorrow as good as they
are today
as good as they are they will be better
in the future
and if you don't believe me just because
fighting is a very subjective thing
there's no instrument of measure just
look at track and field
uh weightlifting uh like
the sport that you can measure we always
talk about oh who's better tyson noeli
or lebron james or michael jordan or
this guy i believe
the most generally speaking the more the
most recent
athletes are always better not because
they're better
person because they have access to
better technology and knowledge
okay well i think that if uh if physical
appearance
was a factor then then you win
you are gorgeous you're the goat for the
best looking ufc fighter
of i'm not all time that
i love telling guys it's gorgeous of all
time yeah
yeah i'm sure i think another another uh
actually you know all kidding aside
important criteria
should be your uh outside of the octagon
life right like i mean as far
as you don't have anything tarnishing
your legacy
for outside of fighting and
that's good i i'm look look i've done a
lot of crazy
i've done a lot of crazy [ __ ] you know
like like like
don't get wrong i i enjoyed my life i i
you know i was a
i had access of to things that
that most people don't i i party a lot
i made a lot of i had a lot of fun and i
enjoyed it uh
you know what i mean i've done all my
crazy stuff and i and i felt good you
know
why would i would fight for if i would
not have if it would not be
to enjoy it i don't fight because i
enjoy to fight i
i fight because of the life that it
gives me the freedom that it provides me
and of course i did a lot of crazy stuff
the problem is i know how to keep it
down i know how to keep it secret you
know
some guys they have a bad entourage they
they go
out party and they they lose their mind
and then you know that's a problem you
know
i have a suspicion i'm buying i'm by no
mean
a monk i party a lot i have a lot of fun
i didn't do it like i i didn't
cross certain lines you know i did not
but but i had a lot of fun like yeah of
course like
some people they think yeah i always
follow a diet and this i don't drink
yeah it's not true i i enjoyed my life
and and and my answer is like why would
i would
why would i would fight all this time
and have that that
career that that crazy career if i if i
couldn't enjoy
it the benefits of it you know what i
mean there's there's a famous line in
rocky when when uh his trainer was like
you know women weak in legs right and so
he didn't want
rocky to blow load before his fight is
that something common in like the ufc
like
before a big fight are you just
completely abstinent for as long as you
can or what's the
what's this are you blowing loads before
you go into the ring to relax
while we're on the subject of sex let me
tell you that people have been asking me
lately
whether blue chew tablets really work
and i can confidently tell you
yes they do in fact my girl lux
loves it so much when i take bluetooth
tablets that just the night before last
she called me upstairs hey babe i made
you a little something to eat
and i walk up there and there's just a
plate with a blue chew
tablet sitting on it i love that
man and what is a bluetooth tablet well
it is a tablet which has the same active
ingredients as both viagra
and cialis except it's chewable and
costs
only a fraction of the price and to get
it is
very very simple you don't have to have
a physical
appointment in a doctor's office which
gets all kinds
awkward no you just go to bluechew.com
and you consult with one of their
medical providers right on there
it's very easy and then voila
your blue chew tablets show up in the
mail what's
even better than that is that i'm going
to hook you up with an entire
month supply for free a whole month
all you gotta pay is five dollars for
shipping
that is if you go to bluechew.com
and use the promo code stevo so now head
on over there
because this thing will give you the
most outrageous
boner you can even imagine i'm telling
you for a
fact i love boning my girl about a half
an hour after i have a blue chew
and i mean it so one more time
bluetooth.com use the promo code stevo
get a whole month's supply of bluetooth
tablets and all you have to pay is five
dollars for shipping
your boner will thank me now let's talk
about sex before the fight
i got a theory on that and it's not
proven but that's what
that's what i truly believe because a
lot of people ask me about that
i believe the more you do it the more
testosterone it is so the more you do
it the better it is the more you you
evacuate
the sure it is because your body will
produce more
and however it will i think it will
raise your testosterone
and i don't think it's a good idea to do
it the day of the fight
of course not but before or the day
before or i i don't think it
it really matter okay so you would think
scott was the most dangerous guy on the
planet because he'll jack off like nine
times in a day
yeah i did it before the podcast yeah
you probably have a very high
testosterone level
i think so that's the problem i think
it's a good thing
i think it's actually a good thing okay
that's why scott can't fight anybody
because he can never go a day without
jackie
it will probably follow the
you will probably fail the uh
performance financing drug testing
so i'm gonna i'm gonna go right right
into this right you're you're known
for for believing in ufos
very very many experiences with aliens
and ufos
and now it's on cnn they're saying
ufos are real like do you feel like
i've told you so for so long i've been
saying so and now you finally believe me
i uh i i never i never had experience
with eldian i
when i was young i did what uh
psychologists call sleep paralysis
so it's a phenomenon that happened that
when it happened to a lot of people
and that's what they tell me that when
you sleep
you you paralyze and your brain produce
certain chemicals that can make you a
loosening
i don't remember my experience what
happened i remember that i had
experience but i didn't remember
what really happened but i remember that
still now today i have
a fear of it even in the dark like i'm
around man i'm 40 years old and
sometimes
some some remnants of it it's in my head
that i'm afraid but i don't know why i'm
afraid when i wake up in the middle of
the night but
it could be it it's described as sleep
paralysis
so and for ufo it doesn't mean you have
flu it's an alien
we don't know like i i it's an
identifier flying object
and i think they changed their name now
for uap
unidentified aerial phenomenon so
we don't know i mean i i personally
believe yes they
i think if we think we're the only one
in the universe i think
i think not that it's wrong but we don't
have the poop but i think the universe
is so big there's probably life
i don't know if they came here but i you
know it wouldn't
it would not surprise me if they did all
right
yeah i mean i mean i haven't even like
been
particularly uh you know up in arms
about it but it seems pretty
interesting that like it's mainstream
media the pentagon is announcing ufos
are real
the funny thing too is people are just
like oh yeah okay like nobody there's no
nobody's freaking out
really like no one's they're just kind
of like soft lobbing us
all this that that's what surprised me
the most
it's crazy they talk about kovind this
should be
the front page of every newspaper i mean
it's
imagine if we i mean maybe it's chinese
maybe you know it's russia i don't know
but imagine if we
because they know now that it's
intelligently controlled
whatever it is you know they the pilot
talk about it
and intentionally jump their radars you
know so that's mean it's it's
intelligently controlled
it's not a phenomenal like a random
phenomenon
from nature yeah that's mean it's really
something like
legit but we don't know what it is it is
you know
it's it's crazy but imagine if we put
our end into this and we can back an
engineer the technology the the now we
we we spend like like a lot of uh
time and then effort on fossil fossil
fuel and all that
all the energy that they had it could
change the planet i think that's
that's the the most rewarding thing
about that that stuff
it could change the world yeah
absolutely
yeah i mean it is it it's pretty
fascinating i mean even with the uh
the colonel favor that was on
everybody's podcast talking about the
little tack
i mean if if they thought that china had
this type of technology like we'd be on
like
you know category five alert but like
because they
don't know what it is like i have no big
deal yeah you know it's pretty it's
pretty crazy
and what about like sorry go ahead
i think the problem is there's a lot of
conspiracy theory
uh about it so this subject has been
ridiculed
for so many times you know it's uh
it's when you want to hide something and
play the best ways to hide it in
in plain sight so to speak you know you
ridicule the subject so everybody is
afraid to talk about it because they
will be ridiculed
right so i think i don't and i don't
know if somebody
knows like but i don't think i mean
i don't think the president of the
united states because it comes and
goes every four years you know so i
don't know if a guy like this would know
every secret
i would tend to say more someone from
the kgb or or the cia or something like
that maybe someone knows
what it is but yeah i don't know man
it's it's it
it's crazy yeah yeah it's an exciting
time to be alive
so so uh dustin poirier he has the hot
sauce
and uh conor mcgregor has the proper 12
and and you know do you have uh like
your own
like business where you sell you sell
something
there's a lot of stuff i i have i mean
mostly in fitness
uh i have a platform called trueconnect
tv.fit
a program called strike and it's a
platform that uh
it's not only about fitness it's about
well-being there's
some help for mental issues on it uh
some some program is for the yoga some
are for uh track and field
my program is for martial art i teach
people how to fight
while i keep them in shape and with some
fitness exercise a little bit like uh a
little bit like taibo but more for mixed
martial art
uh it's a great platform i'm also into a
hydro revolution it's a new equipment
that use the drag of the water
to to train it really changed my life so
that's my
that's my thing i'm more into fitness
than into
alcohol and stuff maybe perhaps one day
i'll do it but not not yet
right okay so these are things that they
that you're promoting you promote the
with the hydro what's it called hydro
revolution
it's a training device that you can use
in the pool
like instead of doing bench press and
pull up you can use
two uh dumbbells in the pool you use a
drag of the water with it
it's fantastic okay yeah i've seen the
youtube videos
send me your address i'll i'll ship you
guys some all right
you guys will give it a try cool so
everybody check out hydra revolution
yeah because i've seen you on youtube
videos doing the swimming pool
uh hydro revolution exactly
and it's it's good for everybody for
older people
young people athletes a linebacker from
the nfl can train
with uh a a lady weigh a 130 pounds you
know so
it doesn't matter it's because it's the
drag of the water that makes the
exercise so the more you push
the more you put the more horsepower you
put in it the more you work so
you can't cheat with it it's great good
cool and it's probably
uh like you won't like you
blow out your back if like you're bent
over like lifting something right it's
probably more safe
exactly yeah it does not load your joint
so
it's great because it keep your body
healthy you know
it's a great compliment for for a
fitness for training
however by itself it's
if you want to be an elite athlete it's
it's you can't use it by itself it's a
great compliment
it's very good for a recovery also for
performance but
you need you need to do the real thing
like outside
because you don't have when you're in
the water you don't have the gravity
that play against you
so it's important in real life you have
the gravity that goes against you
this is more for a side training but
it's a great compliment it's amazing
right good what question do you get the
most at a bar
like uh we were talking to stone cold
steve austin and people like he's like
people always want to come up to me in
arm wrestle or i think michael bisbee
said like
you know do people come up to you and
like i'll always ask you to do something
to them at a bar when you're drinking
out in public
let me tell you that drinking out in
public has always been one of my
favorite things
before and after i became a sober guy
so what does it look like now well i
walk around with my
tall boy of liquid death and what is it
it's not a beer it's the healthiest
mountain water
and sparkling water that you can find on
the market
why is it in a can because plastic
bottles
are for [ __ ] man they fill up the
ocean they ruin the world
and they're not even recyclable anymore
but these
infinitely recyclable aluminum cans
aren't just good for the environment
the water in them isn't just good for
you but
it's a lot of fun you know i talked to
the ceo of liquid death
just yesterday and he told me that he
loves the idea of
little kids in grade school showing up
and drinking this in class
to freak out their teachers making them
think that they're drinking a beer when
they're just drinking
innocent water because that's the kind
of company this is man
it's fun it's healthy and it cares about
the environment so much so
that 10 percent of the profit from every
can sold
goes to bring death to the plastic
yeah dude they donate it i mean i love
this company dude
and i'm gonna pound this right now so
how do you get this
well you go to liquiddeth.como
and you get free koozie with your first
order of any case
yeah dude plus the ceo he skateboards
too love the guy so yeah man one more
time for free koozies with your first
order of any case of liquid death
water go to liquiddeth.com
stevo get behind this company please
because they're a lot of fun
yeah dude now let's talk about what
happens in the bars
they always ask me will you kick me in
the nuts
everybody wants yeah everybody wants me
to kick them in the nuts
i i i i i i can't understand why there's
a guy that i remember
and by the way before if i if i may
you know you almost killed me one time
you you guys with that
the jackass you i was eating a pizza
like
many years ago when i was watching your
movie and i remember you were uh
i don't know if it was you you were
wearing a jack strap and
some alligator was trying yeah
that was that was me dude i
i was eating a pizza while i was
watching it and i almost
got a stroke because you make me laugh
so much i almost died man
i'm sorry that that happened
yeah wow you almost killed me like
literally
literally and who who's who's the one
who fought butterbean
is that's johnny knoxville johnny knocks
it off
yeah just snoring yeah snoring
yeah that was bad dude what's wrong with
man
my brain what was the question that you
just asked what question does he get the
most
oh yeah what questions you get the most
well what do people do do people ask you
to choke me out
no what they do ask me is they come for
example one or two guys and they ask me
is hey
how long you think we could hang with
you
like how long we would last against you
and i don't know i tell them i'm like
well i i
you know it's a i can't answer that
question and they they say
approximately and i ask them i say it
depends
do you carry a gun do you have any
weapons they say no say do you run
fast i'm like yeah maybe you wouldn't
last very long
that's a good answer you mean you mean
hanging out with you like in a fight
yeah how long can we last fighting you
yeah how long would you last into a
fight like if i decide to
to beat them up how long they will how
long they could be able to stem
you know well that's like it's it it's
always
it always depends on every individual
right yeah
well that's like uh when brendan shaw
was talking about you know jon jones
being the goat
they're like he's like he can take out
like 10 guys in a bar and then i asked
him you know how many
how many guys can uh izzy out of sonia
take out he's like he can probably do
like eight just because of his size
how many dudes at a bar do you think you
can [ __ ] up before
you get taken over average guys but it's
always
it always depends which kind of guy you
know like small guy guys he knows how to
fight
guys who has weapon and i was
i was a doorman in a bar and i'm gonna
tell you something
we talk about street fight and mma fight
this is these are two different things
like very different things i remember
some time like even
women were very hard to deal with
because a woman you know in a street
fight like she's gonna grab a bottle and
a woman can hurt you just as bad as a
man you know like like
and in a street there's no rules
so the the fact that you're a champion
in mixed martial arts
it's not a a a hundred percent uh
like guarantee that you will win the
fight you know what i mean
anybody can come behind me tap me on the
shoulder and
if i don't expect it throw a big punch
and knock me out cold
like every what you don't see coming is
what that's what knocked you out
everybody can do it to me i mean i mean
to a certain extent but what i'm saying
is in a street fight
the element of surprise is the most
important thing
and i was bullied a lot when i was young
and
one thing that add to my own my
advantage is
that because i was a nice guy i was
never looking for trouble i had the
limit of surprise because before that
the fight
happened there's no referee that say go
there's something that
that needs to to happen there's a
someone that instigate the fight
and when you feel the heat rising too
much
now you because you're the nice guy
you're on the defense he's the one
looking for trouble
you have the element of surprise and
that gives you a big edge
it's it's like a head start and if you
know how to fight on top of that
it's your chance of winning are like
almost
uh 99.9 wow so always throw the first
punch
always be the never be the aggressor
always be the one
who's uh i mean that's why to be a nice
guy to be
to not look for trouble in a way
if you don't look for trouble and you
know how to fight you have a big
big advantage over anybody who comes
to look for trouble with you because you
have the element of surprise
i'm not talking about someone who does
not know how to fight of course if you
don't know how to fight
you know you don't know what to do with
this situation but if you do know how to
fight
man it's a it's a huge huge huge
advantage
good man do you uh do you watch
every ufc or you don't always wear i'd
like
are you such a fan and you watch it all
the time because i never miss a fight
man i love it
i i i watch all the big one and also now
that i am the french commentator for uh
the the sport channel in canada cool so
because french is my first language i'm
sure you
you realize that my english is not very
good so
french is my number one so i i watch
i do all the big the big shows and i
choose the one that i wanted to do
so i i do all the big pay-per-views i
watched the last one was oliver
against chandler i watched it i i
commented
uh on on tv i watched a youtube video
with you uh
predicting who was gonna win uh
the chandler oliveira but i forget who
you're uh who you picked
did you yeah i i made a mistake i i i
thought chandler would have won would
have win but unfortunately
i mean not unfortunately yeah oliveira
did an amazing job right
he could have gone both sides i mean it
was very
very very very tight it was very very
close to being over at the end of the
first round there's no question about
that
and i was
i was happy for the outcome because of
uh chandler was so over confident he
says oh
oliveira he doesn't have heart that's a
big insult
to say a man doesn't have heart he says
when
when he says when oliveira feels my
pressure
he's gonna question whether he uh
whether he wants to
to even fight he's gonna i'm gonna break
his spirit he's gonna have no gumption
oh man yeah really good for oliveira to
shut that [ __ ] up
but you know you know what i think what
what happened is that when you do those
interviews
the interviewer they tried to they
they dig deep to try to make you say
things
yeah to talk [ __ ] about your opponent
right
right i don't i don't think you
underestimate uh
oliveira i think he was kind maybe
pushed to say something like this
because
fight are promoted on emotions right but
they are not
one on emotions fights are one on
mundane
stuff that you do every day in training
and uh
yeah i i a lot of time you have guys
that will talk a lot of trash
they play mental warfare yeah you know
and uh
like sometimes sometimes it doesn't like
nick diaz he was pretty good at that
exactly nick diaz was good but
not the best uh michael bisping was very
good michael bisping
really was pretty good that that was
that was your last fight michael bisping
is that right yes
michael bisping was pretty good but he's
actually a very nice guy but when you
get into a fight
the fight start the minute you sign the
contract because now
in the media he's gonna make some crazy
declaration
and and you're gonna have to prove him
wrong in the ring and stuff like that
i remember the press conference the the
media
for for you and michael bisping and i
felt like
oh michael bisbang he he won the press
conference but then
you stuck it to him in the octagon yeah
but you know what what what was the best
promotion the best thing we did
promotion wise for that fight
it was not even during the press
conference and i have to give
i have to give it to michael bisping we
were in toronto
during a press conference and he was
talking
[ __ ] to me and i was answering back back
and forth and
i cannot win a a a a trash talk
contest with an englishman because
english is not my first language and on
top of that i'm just not good at it
so of course he was talking trash and
stuff like that and we made that we did
the face off and when we did the face
off
he kind of came too close and he put his
hand on me and i pushed him back
so we went after the press conference we
went our both
separate ways and we went backstage in
the truck
and we were backstage and i remember
they were
there were kids they were coming up to
meet for autograph and michael bisping
his car was is is uh not his car as
limousine was
was parked not far away from mine so
he saw me backstage and he saw that the
tmz was there as well
so he saw the camera the tmz camera so
right away came into my face right away
in front of everybody
and he says to me say and you can you
can check that clip
it's on youtube i believe you can check
it it goes like hey next time you put
your
your 30 yen on me i'm gonna i'm gonna
swing at you
and i told him something like yeah like
go ahead right now let's do it right now
and then we
we got separated by the michael bisping
coaching
so but people really like were
really tuned in into this and and these
kinds of stuff
makes the emotions come coming out
and people want to buy the fight because
fights are promoted on emotion
right so bisping is a very very clever
guy he knows how to promote the fight
did you know that when you had that
fight that he could only see out of one
eye
no i did not i did not i mean i knew i
knew his
his vision from one of the one of his
eye was compromised
but i didn't know it was like that i
mean i didn't know it was a hundred
percent like that it's insane
yeah he's probably the toughest guy in
the ufc
ever i mean tony ferguson tony ferguson
has been racking up some tough points
yeah yeah it's true tony ferguson tony
ferguson
back michael bisping is not too far
behind i gotta say right
right now when i when i met ronda rousey
i was talking to ronda rousey
she was um she was
explaining something that uh jean
labelle
told her you know gene labelle the it's
a judo master
jean labelle said to ronda rousey she's
telling me this
he says uh every i won
every real fight every r-e-a-l
fight i i won and and i was broke i had
nothing to show for it
and then i got into movies and every r
e e l fight i lost
but then then i could retire because i
made so much money
so so with with all the
roles that you've had with the the
captain america
like you're like two captains that's got
to be
is that does that sound about right what
gene labelle says that
it's about right and also lots of fight
with on the big screen i guess
jacqueline van damme steven seagal right
right
i mean they're bad like they're not like
the movie
it's it's i didn't even watch it all
myself you know but there are
movies that i've done in the in the past
but
uh yeah man i've lost pretty much all
the fight that i got into
as as an actor yeah maybe
that's pretty cool so uh so so the
the the marvel movies
pay better than the ufc
no no that's not true um i made a lot
more money
in in ufc i i i i i made a lot a lot
more money in ufc
uh but however there is guys that
we only hear about the people who makes
it
you know what i mean like you hear about
mcgregor you hear about jones you hear
about
like like i made it to i made a great
great money i have enough money now to
live for the rest of my life and even
not even i don't need money anymore yeah
no seriously
unless i do crazy stupid stuff yeah yeah
you know like like
there's always always ways to do crazy
stuff and lose everything
but i have more than enough to live
two three life again you know that i'm
very good i'm very good and and then to
take care of my family as well
but the the the sad
the sad thing about it is most of the
fighters
they're not like that most of the
fighters they will finish
broken and beaten and
and very bad it's it's a very bad movie
ending
you know for most of them that's why
when a parent come with his kids
to me and say and introduce me
is kids as hey george there's the new
the future world champion do you have
some advice for him i always tell the
kid
i say you go to school you say yes i say
make sure you be good at school because
this is the number one priority for you
yeah
go train if you want do boxing mma
basketball
but always be good at school because
it's your it's your assurance
in case something doesn't work at least
you have a nation
an assurance you can you can have a real
job because
if you put all your eggs in the same
basket and
you only want to become a professional
athlete
and if you reach the age of for example
late
20s or 30s and you realize that you
cannot make it
then it's too late that you have nothing
that you can fall
into to catch up and make your
make yourself for the money that you
have lost so i tell the kids yes
try it try to make it big try for a
career but stay
at school and it's same thing not only
in fighting there's one on
100 100 000 same thing in baseball
basketball rt
uh everything yeah so
the the the odds are very very very low
for you to succeed
and it's not because i made it then i'm
gonna tell you a kid to make it right as
well
i i think that's fantastic advice mm-hmm
i yeah what what uh how much does a good
manager play a part of all that
i mean you're with a a lia dolo aziz
right like um
at a certain point are they just sending
over the same contracts or is he just
kind of like helping you negotiate for
more and more and more and more every
time
no i'm with a ca uh and
i was lucky before i got with ca
i was i had advice from
friends that were my friend before i was
popular
so i always had great guidance because a
career of an athlete especially in
combat sport
it's not a straight line and sometimes
it's like when you play poker
you have to blush and i remember times
that
man i'm gonna tell you the truth my
first fight in ufc i made
three thousand dollars plus three
thousand dollars to win
my first ufc title fight against matt
news that i've lost
i i was i was i signed for nine thousand
dollar plus nine thousand dollars
and i lost that fight so i made only
nine thousand dollars
my first ufc fight i made my first
million dollars
i remember around my fight with against
john
fitch and the reason why i made my first
million
i would not have made it if i would have
not not have played my card well
and my advisors would not have advised
me well so what i did is
the way it works in ufc and if there's
young fighters that listen to me
take some note because it's very
important what i'm talking about if you
want to
tie your money to make enough money for
the rest of your lives
and not be broke broke when you finish
pay attention to this
so ufc they're not my friends they're my
employer
and they're there to make business they
run a business and it's okay for me so i
have to look for the best of my interest
so the way it works and ufc is when you
you sign a contract normally they try to
make you sign a contract for multiple
multiple fights so you know how much you
will make for your next fight
your next one if you win and next one if
you win your next one if you want and
let's say you you sign for a
fight fight contract you know how much
those fight fight will
will give you if you win and normally
when as you go in your career that if
you're successful of course
that's mean you're stuck goes i so when
you're at
your fourth fight and you have one more
left
because you're stuck is high they don't
want to lose you they don't want you to
go to fight for other
organization so they want to keep you so
they don't want you to
finish their contract so before your
last fight they're going to try to
renegotiate
with you and they're going to offer you
some things
however it's up to you to make the right
decision
and i remember i was in that situation
at one point before my fight with
uh john fitch and i was fighting for
peanuts
you know and when i say peanuts i was
making money but not money as i
as i was deserving and i wasn't a
dilemma because i had one more fight on
my contract and my stock was high i was
the new
rising star i was that was the new
champion beating up everybody
and the the money that they were
offering me
was not good so uh for
for the what i've done you know for for
my
for my level so i had one more fight
left and i said
in their face i had the courage to say
no i'm going to end my contract after
this one and
stay try my chance to see
to be a free agent because i believe
i worth more money to see who can give
me more
so what happened is one day before my uh
my com my i was i was going to fight the
day after the win
the ufc owner came and
did another another contract for me so
he gave me a contract and the money that
i want and that's when i made my first
millions
of dollars but if i would not have had
the balls
to to do that and hold on to this
i would have be paid peanuts for the
rest of my life
but because it's a business that's how
it goes you need to have the right
advisors
that that because fighting is not a
straight line sometimes you need to put
a poker face and say no i'm
ready to to to take the fight and be a
free agent after
to see who can give me more but if you
do that and you're stuck as i
it's always a chance because you might
lose your fight and your stuff will be
low but if you do that and you're
successful
and the ufc let you go and you when
you're a free agent they're gonna
now it's gonna be like an auction who
will give you more money
so the ufc don't want that because
they're the most prestigious
organization so they
they want to have the most precision the
best fighters
and if if it gonna make them look bad
if they if they lose you to another
organization so you need to be aware of
that
you know but of course you need to win
to win your fight you need to be
successful
of course man i wonder if
uh chandler losing if that's like such
great news for the ufc because it shows
that
the ufc is the more prestigious for the
best in the world
[Music]
but it's it's always a gamble in a way
that
let's say you're in you're in a contract
that you're uh you have a
you have signed a three fight contract
and you have one
your first to fight and now you're about
to fight your your third fight
if the ufc think that you will probably
lose your
your third fight against the guy that
they're gonna give you
they're perhaps not gonna try to renew
your contract before they're not they're
perhaps not gonna give you a good
uh good good contract
uh for for to renew it so
and it's up to you to know hey is it
worth it that i
that i think that i i take a chance and
i become a free agent or or
i want you know what i mean it's right
you have to think about it it depends on
every situation but you need to have
good advisors and unfortunately in mma a
lot of guys they have
very poor very bad advisors and as a
child
i grew up with guys that were my real
friends so they they
they advised me very well so when you're
coming up on that last fight in the
contract
do you think the ufc makes that a very
hard fight for you
so that you you not you don't have that
negotiating power do they
do they play it like that well for me i
was the world champion
so they always brought me the best guy
i was at the time that i didn't care i
was like i was
ready to take on anybody anytime
anywhere i didn't care i was very hungry
bring it no problem my friend i'm gonna
i'm i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna take care of
it but but
for young fighters you know like as it
go
up and rank you need to be aware of that
you know i see some young guys sometimes
they sign contract for
like eight fight deal i'm like it's
ridiculous
because if you're stuck go up
yeah you have no room no no no power to
negotiate because you already signed for
eight fights
so if you win your your first two fight
and you're very successful
your six other fight that's mean the
purse that you're gonna have is
predetermined so you have no power
and a lot of a lot of guys that get
caught with that sort of thing you know
it's it's foolish to think that that
everybody is well managed because a
problem is in them
in basketball in in hockey baseball
american football they have an union
that took care of the the kids
because there there's a there's a
plateau
there's a there's codes you know there
is a rules you know to follow there's a
guideline
we don't have any guideline in mma and
and that's why
that's why a lot of the athletes they
they're broke they have no money and
it's very unfortunate for them for that
yeah wow [ __ ] so you went from making
nine thousand two million
that that kind of yeah yeah two i i i i
made way past that my last fight
way faster
with sponsorship and all that all the
deals i have like about that you know
so just to show you that everything is
possible
and and you you
[Music]
you know what i mean but you need you
need to perform to be a good
fighter first of course otherwise you're
not gonna go nowhere but you need to be
managed well
and i'm managed by ca you know in l.a
and
i had a lot of issues when i was young
you know but like everybody else i had
to go in court and i and i i was
badly advised at first certain as in
certain times but i always had
two or two of my close friends that i
have
for a very long time they one was a
stock broker and then
uh and another one was a real estate uh
not not received a stock stock broker
guy
and the other one was a fiscalist and a
lawyer so they had other jobs in the
past
they they were not working for me but
they were always giving me good advice
and
as time goes on i would add i had enough
money
then i that i hired them to be in my
team
and took care of me and then we went
with ca all together and that's how
everything
happened you know but i was very lucky
so because when you
when you start to make a lot of money a
lot of people
gonna come to you and there's a lot of
sharks and fighting it's a world's uh
world of shark my friends i'm telling
you it's very bad you cannot trust
nobody
and that do you still have a
relationship with ali
oh yeah ali ali is a friend of mine ali
i know him when i when i i was born i
didn't have money i stayed in his house
uh in new york ali is a good friend of
mine with texas shuttler sometime yeah
ali is a manager he managed he does not
manage me but he manages other fighters
uh he manages
a lot of good guys yeah he's got a great
team
man i'd i'd like to to link up with him
yeah
i think i think i've got some funny
ideas when when the ufc gives you a 10
million dollar paycheck i mean
maybe it wasn't all at once but like
when they give do they give you a
breakdown of what
where it's from or is it just a check
well they're just
like pay-per-views or the way the way it
happened the way it happened is they
don't give you one check the way it
happened
in mma like the way it happened for me
you can negotiate depend
your pa your power your level of power
of course if you're
you know it's always depend it's
different
it's different from every fighter but
you have enough power that you can
demand
you know a purse to show first to win
you can demand
a percentage of the gate you can demand
pay-per-views
buy because when i used to fight it was
we made a a lot of money the most of
money i made it was
through pay-per-view buys so i was paid
i was paid uh to fight as a purse but
the most of money came later it was
during the pay-per-view buys
because i was it was making me a partner
so i was also a partner of the company i
was not only an employee i was
a partner because i i had a good
argument i was telling them that because
of me
a lot of people gonna watch the show and
if you make money it's
it's it's fear that i make money too
because i'm bringing
a lot of people to buy the pay-per-view
so
but that's how i used to the system was
different when i used to fight than it
is now well now
um every world champion if you're the
champion
then you get a percentage of the
pay-per-view for for every champion
well not everybody and now i believe the
structure has changed because the
pay-per-view now is
espn i'm not i don't think that the
fighters has as much power now that they
used to be
so like before when i was fighting er
earlier in my career
we were allowed to have a lot of
sponsors you know and we
got paid a lot of money now there's a
reebok deal right and then now it's
venom
so that's why yeah when i came back to
fight michael bisping one of the
arguments
that i was uh were saying with
with my my team and i were like hey yeah
you pay us
a certain amount of money but don't
forget that i lost money because
before i use to get my sponsor now now i
don't get paid for this so reebok need
to pay me or
whatever i'm gonna wear need to pay me
that amount of money
so you need to fight for every inch of
it i don't do that it's not my job it's
not my uh
that's not what i'm good at it's yeah
i'm not you know i'm not qualified to do
that i have
very qualified people that do that for
me and i think a fighter one of
one of his jobs i think it's important
that he choose
carefully his team that he hire people
that he can trust but also people that
are qualified to do the job to represent
him well
so your advice to jon jones would be
take the stipe fight
yeah i mean dude anybody's [ __ ]
advice to jon jones to me take the stipe
fight
what are you thinking i think you should
fight the i think jones
should fight that champion that that's
deeply i think should fight francis and
ganouda champion
okay but that's not a possibility
anymore so
why not because he doesn't want to take
the third one because they're they're
gonna book derrick lewis and then goner
so and then
like what what jon jones wants to do is
wait for the winner of derrick lewis and
in goner so that he's fighting for the
championship
and maybe we disagree george but i think
if he
does take the stupid fight and and he
can win it
then then he's earned everybody's
respect
he gets two fights you know like you can
like beat steve bay
now it's like wow you want that heavy
weight like this is this is crazy like
now we take you very seriously now we
we're really paying attention now we
really even more want to see
you fight for the but why wouldn't izzy
fight the number two guy like why would
izzy go up and fight the champion right
away
i i believe if i if i'm john jones
because
this what we're talking about it's it's
that's what we're talking about it's
like chess game you know
yeah between because these are big these
are
big important decisions that you make
and
you know because fighting there's no way
it's always the questions of odds
doesn't mean if you think you're going
to beat one guy yeah doesn't mean that
even if the odds favor you doesn't mean
that you're always going to win
and i think it would be a mistake for
jon jones to fight steeply i think i
i not because i i believe john jones
will beat stephen however why are taking
the risk
of fighting steepy when you can wait and
fight for the champion
if you can and and collect to belt and
then after john jones is the greatest of
all time if he does that
like man he can run up to the sunset
sunset is
stuck will be as high as
like more higher than anybody ever
and and the world another world will
open for him
you know as he retired he could do
whatever he wants
the problem is guys they hang hang there
in a sport for too long
they they are considered the best but
they ain't there for too long so now
they're
there there's touch goes down and they
retire
as their stock are down so when they
the the door does not open for them
because they're
they they're already broke you know what
i mean they're stuck is is
bad you know yeah so that's why you
should retire on top
you know not not and everybody keep
fighting for different reasons
i do not like to fight personally i did
it because it
gives me my my life my freedom and i
love it
i never like to fight i never enjoy it
one second
i hate it not knowing if i was going to
be
badly hurt or humiliated for me it's
unbearable
that's why i'm a big fan of you guys
what you guys do in the jackass movie
you guys are completely insane and doing
it for
fun i wish i could be like that i mean
you guys are
completely insane i don't i don't do it
for fun at all i do it for attention
i'm an attention [ __ ]
[Laughter]
man he's the best george st
i love that hey what are you thinking
about on on a world title fight
the cage closes are you just zoned in on
like
different moves and techniques or are
you just kind of just waiting for the
bell to go like
what's going through your head before
they go ding ding ding and
do the nerves stop at the fir first
punch
or do they kind of just what's that like
i mean i i just can't imagine
being in the cage i i if you want i'm
gonna
i'm gonna give you a little tour of how
i lived through the week
leading up before a fight awesome
because it started start for me
it start much earlier than that it
started when i signed the contract
even before i signed a contract because
i'm thinking ah
you know i'm watching one fight i'm like
maybe i'm gonna fight this guy or this
guy
normally you when you're a champion you
know who you're gonna fight next
you know the possibilities you know that
you're gonna fight the winner of that
fight
so you're gonna pay attention to the
fight that gonna declare
the number one contender so your
butterfly is
already started and as you watch the
fight you start making scenario is this
guy
i'm gonna do this if this guy i'm gonna
do this so you see your brain
already start for me because i'm
obsessive compulsive that's how it works
then when you know who you're fighting
now you know you're going up against you
right away start making out
scenarios in your head as much as you
think about sex and your lie
in your head i was thinking as i was
thinking about sex
as well but i was thinking about
fighting like
like just as much and the closer you get
to the fight
the cl the more you think about it and
it became it become like a like a
like a mental disease an obsession
because you sometimes when you you have
some visions
and sometimes you see yourself winning
and sometimes you don't
you see yourself in trouble but the
thing is when you see yourself in
trouble
for me one of the trick i have to stay
positive and all that
and control my stress level is when i
see myself losing
i don't let go on that negative
thought i force myself to think of how
i'm gonna take
back the upper hand of that situation
and turn it to my advantage and then i'm
gonna
then i can let go my thought and do
something else in my life
and these thoughts before i fight and
i'm talking about like
like two months sometime two months even
a month two two months all the way to
the fight will
hunt you it hunt me
like crazy every second every minute of
my
existence when i'm driving my car when i
eating
before i go to bed and it's get worse as
the fight goes on it gets worse and it
it it weighs very heavy on my shoulder
and it's crazy it drives me nuts
especially the week of the fight because
you get into press conference
and when you promote a fight you get to
see your opponent and you
the the the print that he left in your
brain
and the scar that he left because he's
talking to you stuff that he's saying
get really to you on an emotional level
so
you're trying to start making imagery
not only about the fight but what you're
gonna say to him and
if you say that how you're gonna answer
back and everything so everything
it's like a fight and it's get worse and
and the week of the fight
you have to lose weight and when you
lose weight
it's not a pleasant experience and
when i'm cutting weight it's very hard
sometimes you want to give up you want
to get out of the sauna
but you always i'm thinking that my
opponent is right next to me
and i'm not allowed to show any weakness
so until i
have made ways i don't show any weakness
then i make weight i
do i go to the weigh-in and
i'm gonna tell you the truth the night
before the fight i never sleep well
never and never never see why because
there's too much scenario in my mind
that is hunted it's hunting my mind i
cannot
sleep i'm turning in my bed then but if
you do this i'm gonna do that and then
i'm turning and then sometimes i see
myself winning sometimes i don't and i
have to force myself to finish on top
it's an obsession and it drives me nuts
so i sleep
very very little the the the few nights
before the fight because i'm
going nuts so the day of the fight when
i wake up
i always tell myself the same thing i
always feel like [ __ ]
and i'm always like man i don't feel
good today i feel like [ __ ] like man i
don't know
probably because i don't sleep well the
night before and i thought at one point
when i was young that this would go away
and with the experience i will be able
to feel better
with that but it got it's getting worse
every time because every fight is bigger
than the last one
and with time you realize that it's
normal and that stress that fear
you cannot let it consume you because
fear is like fire it can help you cook
your food but it can also burn you
and i know that fear and stress will
help me
to increase my reaction time my my
decision-making time so it's my friend
and i embrace it i want it
to i want to be afraid because i know if
i'm not afraid that's me that does
not care about what's gonna happen and i
might not be fighting at the best of my
abilities
so i'm going crazy the whole time i'm
going nuts
but as a team
it cannot be any weak link you know so i
have to showcase
confidence in front of my trainer so
when they ask me hey are you okay
i'm like yes man i'm ready to go i can't
wait man it's gonna be fun
can't wait even though deep down inside
i'm lying because i'm scared as hell
and i'm very uncomfortable you know i'm
terrified
and because i'm thinking i'm like man
maybe i'm going to be humiliated or
something i'm going to get knocked out
you know
cold but these these this this fear
makes me be better and perform at my
best
so all that day the day that i'm
fighting is the longest day of my life
it's crazy because so much stress going
on
until i go to the locker room and when
you go to the locker room for example
in my last fight against michael bisping
it was crazy because
it was like my locker room was cursed
all my training partner was getting
knocked out
all the guys from my team were getting
knocked out they were all coming back in
the locker room all messed up
all of them all like with an
ice bag on the head like knocked out
like it was bad
so i was like freaking out i was
thinking i started thinking myself like
man maybe it's a bad day maybe
we're cursed or even though i'm not
super superstitious i'm like man
maybe in in my gym what we do is not
right maybe we
we don't do the right thing and we you
know what i mean
we're we're all as busy you know maybe
things we're not as good as we think
maybe we need to change our mittens and
then the fight get close
then you see you watch a fight on tv and
you don't you never know
you try to predict at what time you're
gonna go on
you know you're the last fight so you
see some guys getting knocked out and
you're like okay now i need to warm up
because it's coming out soon
and as you warm up
it changed something in your mind
because when you start hitting the pads
it makes your confidence grow and this
the
the scare guy that i was before now
start to disappear
because i'm starting to get confidence
because
i remember the mechanic of my movement
the perfection of my punches
and my technique and everything and
making me remember how good i am and
oh yeah this i'm i can't do that well
you know like now i remember
how good i am how much i'm uh i'm a
beast in the gym
you know i'm how much uh the sacrifice
i've done to be here
you know how much i i took care of
myself for for that preparation how much
hardcore sparing i had i'm sure he
didn't have the hardcore spy ring that i
that i had to go to i'm sure he didn't
have the he didn't make the sacrifice
that i did
you know i'm sure he didn't fought those
beasts that i had to fight during my
training camp
i had to go to hell to my training camp
i'm sure he didn't go to the same hell
that i
did start makes you remember to say then
you became a different person
and then times fly and and now there's
someone in the ufc that come knock at
your door and say hey saint pierre are
you up next
so when that moment come i have a little
ritual that i do
i go in the bathroom i look at myself in
the mirror i'm alone
and only my coach knows what i'm doing
and i'm looking myself in the mirror and
i try to
make my confidence go and i'm talking to
myself you know i'm not a
i'm not a cocky person in public but i'm
trying to be
in in private when i'm talking to myself
i'm i'm telling myself like
i'm stronger than him i'm better than
him i'm more well prepared i'm way more
athletic than he is
you know i i went through hell you know
i'm a
much much better fighter i'm gonna win
this fight i'm gonna show these young
kids that lose their fight tonight all
things should be done
and i'm gonna show them that i'm the i'm
the [ __ ] king in this gym
i'm gonna they're gonna i'm gonna give
the example and then and then i'm then
i'm
kicking out the door and i'm a different
person than when i came
so the journalism creator you see now
today is not the same than the one that
is going to fight and and
is about to step in the octagon and when
i kick the door
and i'm about to do my walk now it's on
cruise control
i don't have time to think because if i
think i miss the opportunity
i miss and and i can get clip so it's
all about cruise control
it's like when you play golf you hit the
ball
the ball is in the air there's nothing
you can do
to change the result of the fight to
change the outcome
because all my work is done now the only
thing i can do is
to do it to to to let myself go with the
cruise control to trust my instinct
that's how it goes [ __ ] yeah yeah
dude i love it so is it kind of you're
coming
but people are like oh i come you don't
like to fight yeah i
i don't like to fight because the person
i am now
is different than the person that is
getting ready to step into the octagon
we're both different human beings
so you're you're operating a lot of
instinct in the
oct in in the fight so does are you ever
like
three seconds later you're like oh wow i
just i've just blocked a really cool
like you don't even realize what's what
you know what's happening as it's
happening you're kind of
you're on a delay like your brain is on
a delay almost
now this is after when you watch the
tape
because what happened is in training
you do so many repetition and repetition
and repetition you
you drill certain techniques a thousand
times
so it become like an automatic in your
brain it's an action reaction
you know when you you you have a certain
action you give the reaction in order to
give you the upper end and the fight
and you drill that so many times that it
become automatic
so when you fight you're on cruise
control everything you do
it's a reflection of what you've been
working on
through the last past 10 years
of your life and i say 10 years maybe
you're the last past
30 30 years because i started when i was
a kid you know
so it there there's no uh accident
i believe that everything happened
because of a reason because you
your your reaction everything is a cause
and effect
you know and and that's how it goes wow
it was interesting when they interviewed
i i saw gachi walking back to his locker
room after the ferguson fight and they
were like man it's crazy like you threw
some leg kicks in there he's like
i [ __ ] threw some leg kicks in there
like like
holy [ __ ] like he didn't even remember i
mean it's
yeah yeah about it you you're on cruise
control
for me i remember in one of my fights
i came back it's a five-round fight when
you fight for a championship it's
it's five rounds i was fighting johnny
and drix
after my third round i got rocked in my
third round
after sorry after the second round i got
rocked in the second round
so i go back in the stool and my
my corner men are like hey george this
is the final round it's
2-2 the this is the fifth round is
the one that gonna win this round gonna
win the fight so it's a this is a
decisive round you have to give
everything you got you know if you want
to stay champion you have to give it all
and i look at the guy i'm like guys
you're making a mistake
it's the third round and they're like no
george is the fifth round
and i look at the the screen i'm like
[ __ ]
yeah it's the it's the fifth round
because i got rock i lost
time oh my gosh oh my god so i was on
cruise control that whole time so that's
why i'm that's why i mean
it's a normal thing we're on survival
mode
you can't say i play baseball i play
soccer play basketball but you don't
play fighting
and this is something that we all have
inside o of ourselves i can put anybody
in in a situation that he's gonna have
to fight
either to protect himself or to protect
someone that he loves
i can put everybody i don't care the
nicest person
i can put in a situation like my mother
who's the nicest person i know
i can put her in a situation that she
would be forced to fight in order to
protect her kids
she will she cannot do it well of course
she's not a fighter but she will
so fighting we can all relate to it
because it's something that we all have
to do
at least once in in our life you know
like
it's something that we can relate it's
in in our
most basic instinct that's why it's not
like playing basketball it's it's
fighting it's different
and the proof of that if you don't
believe me look at
what happened if you go watch a
basketball game or a baseball game
and the fight breaks out in the stair in
the in the crowd
you will stop watching the game and look
at the fight because the fight is
threatening
it's it's threatened threatening you it
it
it it as something different a different
appeals
to what is going on as a game maybe you
don't like that
that sort of of uh entertainment you
know
and it's not an entertainment that is
made to everybody but everybody can
relate to fighting
yeah that's crazy so so on the uh the
platform
where you teach people the mma
where uh this is
you say you you can put people in these
situations and
that that's how you do it on the planet
you put people in the situations on the
the platform and when you teach people
yeah what i do is i teach them the basic
fundamentals
of mixed martial arts um
so what they do they can't train like a
fighter the same movement that we do
except they don't have to get the same
damage
that we have to get when when we're
training for a fight you know you don't
get brain damage you know so they can
train
they can repeat the same movement and
explain the details
of how to do it well and how do they
stay in shape at the same time
and how do people get this training from
you how do they find the platform
this is it's called trueconnect tv.fit
it's on your cell phone you can download
it tv.fit
and my program is called strike tv
dot fit fifth my program is it's
strike there's many other programs
there's like
there's stuff for track and field like
whatever but my program is
it's strike like a strike okay good
do you have a program on there to teach
guys how to pick up on chicks because i
feel like you got all those dialed in
man
that maybe it would be my next one
all right so what what so we we send
people to
george st pierre strike on fit.tv
and we send them to buy uh
hydro revolution
revolution uh
bundle and you can go to tv.fit
the program stretch okay and uh and what
about your social media
my social media is it's george samplier
it's on on instagram at
george saint pierre no no dash or the
instagram
all right good man what an amazing
conversation with an amazing person man
and anya on his birthday yeah i feel
like it's our birthday
right it's really yeah
i'm very glad to talk to you guys it was
a pleasure hey man the pleasure is ours
and thank you so so much man
yeah man i keep doing what you guys do
you look great
steve you look you look great man [ __ ]
you i'm glad
a guy like you normally could have died
maybe
25 times but i'm glad you're looking
good and everything man you guys are
good
hey thank you so much man right on man
gsp
dude just telling you how it is man i
really like that guy
and i love the ufc man and i love liquid
death
that's all i got [ __ ] yeah man thanks
for hanging around until the end